Was möchte mir Windows mitteilen?
Ahja, ok, Windows Logik, verstehe, ich habe OneDrive nicht, ich bin in OneDrive nicht
angemeldet, das ist natürlich eine Security-Issue, ganz klar.
Natürlich, was auch sonst, meine Maus geht nicht, geht meine Maus nicht, wartet mal.
OBS geht noch, sehr schön, oh, schon direkt hier, Sub am Start, das ging ja instant,
wen haben wir denn hier, den HS-Yohi, Stufe 1, 3 Monate am Start, danke schön, huge Sub.
Du warst aber sau-mäßig schnell.
Das ist ja fast schon das Gegenstück, wie man auf YouTube früher gesagt hat, die Abo-Box-Camper,
das ist hier der Twitch-Channel, für was der direkt am Start ist, instant.
Erst mal ein bisschen Zeug ausschalten.
Meine USB ist übrigens verreckt, ich habe sie ja auf Twitter geschrieben, aber das Ding
lässt sich auch nicht wieder in Gang setzen.
Ich habe sie jetzt aufgeladen, zwei Tage ohne was dran und das geht an, aber macht komische
Geräusche.
Wen haben wir denn alles am Start schon hier, der RealRenex ist da, Crash, Fluffy, HS-Yohi,
der auch gerade gesagt hat, wir haben Maggi111, der Netto-Assi ist auch am Start.
Ich zeige euch mal, was ich für einen USB habe, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es sich
lohnt, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es sich lohnt, dass ich mir, your orders, ich bin
mir nicht sicher, ob es sich lohnt, dass ich eine neue Batterie kaufe, CyberPower, da habe
ich mal meine USB, die ich hier am Start habe, das Ding hier, so, guckt mal, also dieses
Ding hat schon mal einen äußerst griffigen Produktnamen, muss man sagen, OR600ELCDRM1U,
alles klar, das ist wirklich Next Level Produktname, also wie auch immer, ich meine, das hat
schon alles seinen Sinn, also OR, keine Ahnung, das hier ist die Leistung von dem Ding, das
da ist keine Ahnung und das da ist REC-Mount, eine Höhen-Einheit, aber ich hätte im Leben
nicht gedacht, dass die USB mal das ist, warum mein Zeug hier daheim abkackt, ich meine,
es war nicht weiter wild, das ist halt abgekackt und ich habe, jetzt ergibt es bei mir auch
alles Sinn, jetzt ergibt es bei mir auch irgendwie alles Sinn, ich habe nämlich letztens drüben
bei mir im Bett gelegen abends und irgendwann so um 23.30 Uhr oder so, ich habe schon mehr
oder weniger gepennt und auf einmal habe ich es piepsen gehört und ich dachte mir so,
hä, was war das, hast du irgendwie ein YouTube-Video auf dem Tablet laufen oder was ist das, bin
ich aufgewacht, habe geguckt, alles aus, es kam irgendwie aus dem Schrank, wir sind arschschwach
sind, das kam wahrscheinlich von der Straße, hat sich nur so angehört, als käme es aus
dem Schrank, im Nachhinein ergibt es das Sinn, das war die USB, das war die USB, die wahrscheinlich
gepiepsen hat und hat den Motto, ich bin kurz vorm Verrecken und nachdem das aus dem Schrank
kam, ist auch klar, weil in meinem Schlafzimmer steht der Schrank an der Wand, wo im Arbeitszimmer
quasi dann schräg gegenüber das Rack steht mit der USB und was hatte deine Heizungspumpe
fest und Ausdehnungsgewicht, ich weiß es, ich weiß es noch nicht, der Heizungs-Man da
ist morgen am Start, das ist sehr merkwürdig, es geht mal und mal geht es nicht, ich vermute
mal, dass es in irgendeiner Art und Weise undicht ist, weil man muss halt permanent
Wasser nachfüllen.
Können wir uns mal Icinga, Icinga, wie spricht man das eigentlich aus, diese Nagios-Frog-Geschichte
anschauen, wir könnten uns das anschauen, allerdings ist das so ein Monitoring-Ding,
um den ich ein bisschen die Bogen mache eigentlich, also persönlich jetzt, warum kann ich den
Skype nicht ausschalten und ich kann Skype nicht ausschalten, gebated, das ist nicht
möglich, ich kann Skype nicht ausschalten, na gut, warum habe ich Skype überhaupt noch
installiert, so ein Kack da, genau, es ist irgendwie merkwürdig, ich hätte nie im Leben
gedacht, dass ausgerechnet die USB dafür sorgt, dass der ganze Kram abkackt, das ist
zwar alles abgekackt und im Endeffekt war ja auf der 4HE-Kiste schon gar nichts mehr
in Betrieb, deswegen im Endeffekt, ich habe jetzt einfach umgestöpselt, ich habe umgestöpselt,
alles was an der USB angeschlossen war, das waren mehr oder weniger nur die Steckdosen-Leiste
im Rack und habe es jetzt halt an die Steckdosen angeschlossen, es geht wieder, so und wo
ich mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher bin ist, also das ist das Ding hier, das ist die USB, die
ist auch schon ein bisschen älter, aber ich meine bei USB tut sich nicht allzu viel, die
USB ist glaube ich Release Date oder irgendwie 2013 oder so, aber who cares, was juck mich
der Wandel-USB rausgekommen ist, die funktioniert ganz gut, allerdings die Batterien sind wahrscheinlich
im Arsch, weil ich habe es jetzt 2 Tage aufgeladen ohne was dran und wenn ich es jetzt einschalte,
dann geht es zumindest wieder das Display an, das Ding piepst halt wie verrückt, dass
die Batterie leer ist, das heißt also, das ist im Arsch die Batterie, so und ich weiß
jetzt nicht so genau, ob sich das lohnt, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht so genau, ob sich das
lohnt mir eine neue Batterie zu kaufen, was kosten sowas, Battery, oh ja das ist leider
kein, die USB hat leider kein RGB, was ja schonmal 50% der Leistungsfähigkeit ausmacht,
da sind wir uns ja einig, übrigens Leute, wisst ihr wie man Google auf Afrikanisch
ausspricht, ich guck gleich mal nach der Batterie, ich muss euch mal was cooles zeigen, wisst
ihr wie man Google auf Afrikanisch ausspricht, wartet mal, das ist zu geil, Leute ich wusste
nicht, wie ich die Musik ausmache, das ist zu geil, so geil, Google, falls ihr von immer
wisst, wisst ihr wie man Google auf afrikanisch ausspricht, ich kann mir das echt den ganzen
Tag anhören, Google, Google, so geil, Google, so geil, ich wundere mich ganz ehrlich, warum
hat das Video nicht mehr Views, das ist eigentlich nur ein Video, das müsste eigentlich 50 Billionen
oder so haben, Google, Google, weißt du wie man in the beginning auf Afrikaans ausspricht,
keine Ahnung, wie soll ich das wissen, moin, kannst du das Asrock Yacht 5005 ETX empfehlen,
ja, das ist ja mehr oder weniger das was ich in meiner aktuellen Kiste, Zwerferkiste auch
drin habe, wo ich die, ich hatte ja vorher so einen fetten 8 Kern Xeon Ding rumstehen
und jetzt habe ich auch so was ähnliches hier, also ich habe jetzt ja ein J41 Ding,
das ist die kleine Variante von dem was du da rausgesucht hast, das habe ich jetzt aktuell
als Board in meiner Zwerferkiste, braucht so gut wie keinen Strom, hat jetzt auch nicht
die Wahnsinnsleistung, allerdings mehr als so ein Raspberry Pi wahrscheinlich je jemals
haben wird und das ist nicht schlecht, das ist nicht schlecht, ich meine du schreibst
du willst das für einen Proxmox Server haben, da ist natürlich die Frage wieviele VMs willst
du drauf laufen lassen und wie viel Leistung soll das ganze haben, also Proxmox Server installieren
kannst du da mit Sicherheit easy drauf, das wird auch ohne jegliche Probleme funktionieren,
wenn du da jetzt allerdings 5-6 VMs drauf haben willst, die ordentlich Leistung brauchen,
dann geht das natürlich nicht, aber wenn es einfach nur zum probieren ist, klar, das
sind ziemlich gute Boards, ich weiß gar nicht wie es mit der Nachfolge Generation von diesen
Dingern aktuell aussieht, guck mal mal ob es da bald was gibt, Gmini Lake Refresh, die
gibt es schon, aber wahrscheinlich gibt es da keine Mainboard, wie heißen die Dinger,
Gmini Lake Refresh, gibt es da schon Mainboards für N412, ach ne das ist der, da gibt es
wahrscheinlich gar keine Mainboards, das hat wahrscheinlich nicht ein Hersteller mitgemacht
bisher, es gibt irgendwelche Notebook Dinger und so, das bringt nichts, ich will wissen
wie da wirklich wann der echte Nachfolger kommt, Skyhawk Lake, Jasper Lake, kann sich
Intel mal irgendwie überlegen wie sie ihren Kram nennen, dass ich noch durchblicke, das
ist mir zu big brain die Intel CPU Benamung, Elkhart Lake, ja was denn du, ich blicke nicht
mehr durch, das ist mir einfach egal, ich ignoriere das jetzt bis es raus ist, so was
kosten hier eine Batterie für meine USB, ach ja ich habe ein bisschen Chat übersehen,
ich habe mir ein Tool Instalint in dem man Windows App rausschmeißen kann, MSMG kann
ich dir empfehlen, was, ich habe mir ein Tool Instalint in dem man Windows App rausschmeißen
kann, ich habe keine Ahnung was du mir sagen möchtest, das leuchtet mir gerade nicht ein,
Max was hattest du eigentlich als Thema in der Abschlussarbeit, ich habe ein Layer 2
VPN gebaut für Telefone, mit OpenVPN, OpenVPN an 2 Standorten mit 2 1HE IBM Servern verbunden
per Layer 2 OpenVPN und habe dann Telefone, IP Telefone an die Telefonanlage angebunden
quasi über das Layer 2 VPN so als wären sie direkt im gleichen Gebäude drin, hast du
schon den neuen PC von Montana Black gesehen, nee, wollen wir uns das mal angucken, Montana
Black neuer Ultimate PC, ok Montana Black hat mit dem PC zu viel zu tun wie Michael Schumacher
mit irgendwie Snickers, ich habe keine Ahnung ob der jemals Snickers Werbung gemacht hat
oder was, wieviel Watt braucht das Teil mit meiner Konfig kann ich dir sagen, ich drehe
mich mal um, 13,8 gerade, 13,8 das ist mit 10 Gigabit Netzwerkkarte drinne, einer 12
Terabyte und einer 12 Terabyte HDD, die natürlich runtergefahren ist, wenn die anfährt dann
braucht es ein bisschen mehr, ok was ist das hier, Mythcom, das ist irgendwie unglücklicher
Name oder, Mythcom präsentiert Montana Blacks neuer Ultimate PC, na gut dann schauen wir
mal, ja Flo96 da habe ich auch dran gedacht, der Name ist irgendwie unglücklich, ok die
machen schon mal ordentlich krass, warum genau zeigen die mir einen PS4, einen PS4 Disc wenn
es ein Ultimate PC ist, wir haben die Ehre, welch Ehre ich darf ein PC bauen und Namen
drauf schreiben, krasse Ehre, ich will nicht wissen was das kostet, das ist nicht umsonst,
also was ich meine ist, es ist nicht so, dass, also die müssen dafür ja was bezahlen, das
ist bestimmt nicht günstig, das liegt aber auch daran, wenn jetzt natürlich alle Fanboys
hingehen und sagen dem Motto, Papa, Papa ich will Montana Blacks PC, der Sprecher muss
da aber auch ganz nah an das Mikrofon ran, dass das besonders männlich klingt, ok mal
gucken was da drinnen ist, Top Secret Leute, Top Secret, aber das ist halt so, dass es
so ist, aber das ist halt eine ordentliche CPU, warum ist das so leise, ach ist das zu
leise, ich kann das ruhig lauter machen, dachte das wäre laut genug, das ist natürlich eine
ordentliche CPU, allerdings rein zum Spielen ist das natürlich einmal Overkill und wahrscheinlich
sogar ein Ticken langsamer, als CPUs mit nicht ganz so viel Kern, aber wenn du damit auch
Videos schneiden sollst und rendern und so, warum nicht, kann man machen, das ist das
schlechteste Ding nicht, die CPU kostet halt irgendwie nur 1500 Euro oder sowas, aber er
schneidet doch selber keine Videos, ja und, dann geht es doch bei dem PC nicht drum.
Ja trotzdem, ich bin kein SLI Fan, auch wenn man sich es leisten kann, ich bin nach wie
vor kein SLI Fan, äh, das kann man auch so, da braucht man keine zweite Grafikkarte für,
das hat eigentlich mit dem einen überhaupt nichts zu tun, also du kannst ohne Probleme
den Encoder verwenden, wenn du gerade was spielst, das eine und das andere hat wenig miteinander
zu tun, oh, allein so das Mainboard kostet 700 Euro wahrscheinlich, und dann spielt
der Fortnite in 1080p, ich finde es ja, ich finde es ja, muss ja, habe ich schon öfters
gesagt, ich finde es ja mittlerweile voll grotesk, ne, dass SSDs schon ein Passivkühler
braucht.
Kann man dann, kann man dann Casino Slots in 80k spielen?
Also mir gefällt er nicht.
Also mir gefällt die Optik nicht, es ist nicht, man kann jetzt nicht sagen, das Ding ist hässlich
oder so, aber für mich muss ein PC nicht glänzen.
Ich meine, Gestyling ist das sicherlich ziemlich gut gemacht, ja, und das Ding sieht auch so
aus, als wäre es handwerklich gut gemacht, aber, äh, also mir gefallen tut er mir nicht,
mein PC sieht halt ganz normal aus, schwarze Kiste und das, was für mich ja schon Hightech
ist, dass ich da ein Glasfenster nebendran habe, anstatt einfach ein schwarzes Gehäuse.
Das Problem davon ist, dass man diese Crap-IQ-Software laufen lassen muss, der Name hat, also ne,
dass das Ding IQ heißt, ist ja schon komplette Verspottung von Big Brain Leuten, weil die
Software ist absolut nicht Hightech-IQ, die braucht 5% CPU-Leistung im Hintergrund permanent
für nichts.
340 LED´s, allein in den Lüftern, zum Steuern von 3,5 in den Brusts, 3,5, hab ich das richtig
gehört?
340 LED´s nur vor den Lüftern, das gibt natürlich nochmal 30% Boost, Pro M, 2 Monate, Twitch
Prime, Dankeschön, huge, huge sub.
Das Ding Gehäuse-LED´s haben wir eine zentrale Software, nämlich IQ, dort gibt es verschiedene
Previews.
Oh Gott, Crap-Ups, oh diese Software, ich hab´s wieder, ich war so froh, als ich mein
Corsair, als ich die K95 ausgewechselt hab, gegen ein aktuelles Logitech-Keyboard, ich
war so froh, dass ich diese IQ-Software deinstallieren konnte, das könnt ihr euch nicht vorstellen.
Jetzt wählen, wie Regen oder Visier.
Wer aber keine Lust hat auf Presets, der kann sich auch selber Custom-Profiles erstellen,
das haben auch wir getan und so Montes Designer schaffen.
Das, ich bin mir noch nicht sicher, ist das so ein reines Prestige-Ding, ist das so ein
reines Prestige-Ding für MifCom, wo die sich denken, ok, wir können damit Werbung machen,
aber kaufen wird´s keiner, oder ist das so ein Ding, wo man wirklich von aus geht, dass
es so die Ultra-Hardcore-Fanboys kaufen.
Aber ihr fragt euch bestimmt schon seit dem Intro, was hat das mit dem Playstation-Game
auf sich.
Wir haben eine PS4 Pro Custom-Wasser gekühlt und in Montana Blacks PC integriert.
Nahtlos und mit sämtlichen Anschlüssen und dem Laufwerk.
Die Wasser-Kühlung sorgt dafür, dass die Konsole flüsterleise läuft und die Lautstärke
ist eine Sache, die Montana schon öfters an der Playstation gestört hat.
Aber meine Kollegen haben sich gesagt, das reicht immer noch nicht, wir beim MifCom haben
hohe Ansprüche.
Jetzt kommt noch eine Xbox dabei, ha?
Na komm, jetzt hättet ihr zumindest noch ne Switch und ne Xbox einbauen können, wenn
ihr da schon mal dabei seid.
Ich mein die Capture-Cut ist ne Jübel.
Was ich ja cool finde, dass bei dem ganzen Deal noch nicht mal drin war, dass Montana
Black selber ein Wort oder so dazu sagt, und es war wahrscheinlich noch zu teuer genug.
Vor allem Kohle.
Aber, Monte wartet schon auf die Rakete und ihr seid bestimmt auch schon gespannt, wie
das aussieht, wenn er das erste Mal mit dem neuen PC live geht.
Und ich bin gespannt, wie das aussieht, wenn er das erste Mal mit dem neuen PC live geht.
So, wieder am Start.
Und ich bin gespannt, wenn er das erste Mal mit dem neuen PC live geht.
Echt?
Ich bin gespannt, wenn er das erste Mal mit dem neuen PC live geht.
Und ich bin gespannt, wenn er das erste Mal mit dem neuen PC live geht.
Okay, okay.
Ab hier.
Immerhin, immerhin kümmert sich der Support drum.
Was? Was? Moment, ich blick, ich blick immer durch.
Ja, das ist schon richtig, wenn man das Meldenbord tauscht, aber das müsste doch Amazon auch klar sein.
Aber wenn ich die 81 Dollar an Amazon bezahlt habe, sagt das, dass das Service in der 81 Dollar Estimaten beträgt. Weißt du was ich meine?
Zumindest gibt Amazon zu, dass da halt Mist steht, das ist doch schonmal nicht schlecht.
Dann weißt du wenigstens woran du bist und wahrscheinlich hätte Amazon auch keine Schmerzen gehabt, wenn du jetzt gesagt hättest, ey ne lass mal cancel, will ich doch nicht haben.
Also was du eigentlich sagst, ist, dass das Amazon Quote ist, dass die 81 Dollar, die sie beträgt, voll falsch sind.
Also das ist wirklich Amazons Problem. Ich dachte es war vielleicht einer der Techniker.
Also genau das doppelte, exakt das doppelte.
Aber mal ganz einfach abgesehen, ich würd kein random dude an meinem Rechner rumschrauben lassen, aber das ist aber was anderes.
Es geht ja hier drum, dass irgendwelche casual Leute nicht in der Lage werden, sich selbst Meldenbord einzubauen.
Also eins muss man ja sagen, der Amazon Support gibt sich schon Mühe.
Also ich hab auch schon ein paar Mal bei der Amazon Hotline angerufen, die ist ja ein bisschen versteckt in Deutschland bis man die findet.
Die Amazon Hotline die haben mir bisher auch immer gut geholfen.
Was du mir sagst, ist, dass das wahrscheinlich das Beste, was du tun kannst, ist, um die Kosten von 220 zu 170 zu bringen.
Jetzt machen die so ne Show, sag einfach ja, ich will wissen was der Techniker macht.
Ja, aber wenn das Amazon schreiben würde, würde das wahrscheinlich auch nicht sein.
Wenn das Amazon schreiben würde, würde das wahrscheinlich auch keiner machen.
Na immerhin, immerhin, in Deutschland hätten viele Anbieter gesagt so nach dem Motto, wenn sie das nicht wollen, dann kommen wir halt an dich.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt. Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Er hat ja gesagt, der ist wirklich sehr dedicated, also der ist voll bei der Sache der Techniker.
Ich muss mal kurz hier die Heizung anschalten, auf volle Pulle.
18,7 Grad.
Was macht der denn da? Na gut, das ist Wasserkühlung.
Wenn du ordentlich aufpasst, okay aber zwei Stunden ist schon krass viel.
Jetzt schaltet er bestimmt an und es geht nicht mehr.
George sieht irgendwie ein bisschen Kokona aus.
Ich bin sehr freundlich, das hat eigentlich meine ganze Meinung von ihm gemacht, nachdem das Schöpeln passiert ist. Aber als er hier war, war es ein totaler 180 und mein ganzes Schild, als ich untergekauft war, wollte ich lernen.
Ich wollte ihn die ganze Zeit schaduieren und er war sehr hilfreich, mir kleine Dinge zeigen, mir Tipps geben und seine Wissen in einer Art und Weise, in der ich mehr Interesse in lernen wollte.
Das finde ich gut, dass er das dem erklärt, das ist doch top.
Okay.
Tomahawk Max.
Ja gut.
Gut, das kann immer was passieren.
Das merkt man ja schnell.
Das ist schon ordentlich.
Mehr schadet ja selten.
Läuft halt ein bisschen eben raus, aber...
Ist das das Strom? Ist das das Stromkabel für die Wasserkühlung oder was? Was ist das für eine Kugel?
Ist das das Stromkabel für die Wasserkühlung oder was? Was ist das für ein Stromkabel, für ein USB Kabel, was der da hat?
Das habe ich jetzt nicht kapiert.
Moment, Moment, Apple-Users kaufen sich Einbauservices, da kannst du doch überhaupt nichts einbauen dran.
Was willst du an Apple Rechnern großartig einbauen?
Früher konntest du da einen RAM-Riegel reinstecken, ich glaube das geht heute noch nicht mal mehr.
Da gibt es doch überhaupt nichts zu bauen.
RAM geht das noch, okay.
Dongle-Service, genau, das brauchen wir unbedingt.
Bis jetzt ist es doch gar nicht ganz okay.
Ich sehe da überhaupt keinen Unterschied, außer dass hier die Dinger so sind und da mal so, aber ansonsten sehe ich da keinen Unterschied.
Das macht dem Kabel jetzt nichts.
Aber für 220 Dollar, also der Typ hat zwei Stunden da rumgemacht, da sind 220 Dollar eigentlich vollkommen in Ordnung.
Also bis jetzt würde ich nicht sagen, it's a scam, der Techniker hat doch.
Boah, das ist aber cool, das ist cool, dass das Mainboard einem das sagt, ohne Scheiß.
Früher hat der Kram entweder einfach nur gepiepst oder es ging und war halt performance-mäßig nicht optimal.
Das ist cool, dass einem das sagt.
Wisst ihr was ich mich frage, wenn er das BIOS hätte flaschen müssen und der Rechner hätte nicht funktioniert, wie hätte er sich einen USB-Stick gemacht zum BIOS flaschen?
Oder kann man aus dem BIOS, oder kann man aus dem BIOS rausflaschen?
Aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass man das BIOS flaschen kann, wenn die CPU drin ist, mit der es nicht bootet.
Also müsste er die CPU nochmal wechseln, der hätte länger gebraucht als eine halbe Stunde dafür.
Ja, XSUNNY kann man machen, allerdings wenn der CPU drin ist, wo der Rechner nicht mehr bootet, kann man hier halt nicht ins BIOS.
Bootet er mit der falschen CPU auch ins BIOS? Aber wenn er jetzt bis ins BIOS booten kann, dann funktioniert die CPU ja.
Keine Ahnung, ich hab ja nicht gemacht.
Das klingt erstmal jetzt unlogisch, dass wenn das Mainboard die CPU nicht supportet, dass er dann überhaupt bootet.
Würde mich auch wundern, wenn er bootet.
Kommt man nicht sogar ohne CPU ins BIOS? Nö.
Dann wird angezeigt, dass keine CPU installiert wurde. Wie wollen die das machen ohne CPU?
Wahrscheinlich hängt es ein bisschen davon ab. Vielleicht hängt es ein bisschen davon ab.
Mich würde es nicht wundern, wenn Mainboard die CPU nicht supportet.
Vielleicht hängt es ein bisschen davon ab. Vielleicht hängt es ein bisschen davon ab.
Ich würde mich nicht wundern, wenn Mainboards nicht heute noch einen kleinen Controller drauf hätten, um Fehlermeldung anzeigen zu können, wenn die CPU nicht geht.
In den eigenen Chip bringt der nichts. Du brauchst deine eigene CPU.
Das Flaschen ohne CPU geht halt auch nicht. Irgendjemand muss ja den Kram berechnen und das Flaschen machen.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es vielleicht schon Mainboards gibt, die einen kleinen Controller drauf haben, der auch funktioniert.
Und das Mainboard managen kann, wenn keine CPU drin ist. Würde mich nicht wundern.
Bei Servern gibt es ein komplettes Management-Interface, was unabhängig vom Rest funktioniert.
Also ganz ehrlich, ich muss mal sagen, it's a scam. Also der Techniker war doch jetzt echt nicht schlecht, oder? Jetzt mal chat.
Der hat zwei Stunden rumgebastelt. Am Ende hat es 220 Euro gekostet. Amazon hat vorher auch zugegeben. Es ist Mist, was sie hingeschrieben haben. Sie haben ihm noch einen Gutschein gegeben.
Also das macht mir einen ganz guten Eindruck. Also ich sehe jetzt da nicht das große Problem drin.
Am ehesten, am ehesten noch ein Scam von Amazon. Aber so wirklich Scam insofern ist es auch nicht.
Weil sie haben ihm das sofort gesagt. Sie haben ihm das sofort gesagt.
Ein Scam wäre es gewesen, wenn er das gemacht hätte und danach gesagt hätte, ey jetzt hätte ich gerne 220 Euro. Also eigentlich ist daran nichts Scam.
Was wollen wir denn als nächstes angucken? Wollen wir uns noch mal den Test zum Black Mesa Remake angucken? Aber eigentlich müssen wir uns den Test nicht angucken, weil wir haben es selbst durchgespielt im Stream schon. Fast durchgespielt.
Was hast du denn bei Link bekommen? Was? Wann? Wo? Nee. Hab ich nicht.
Ich glaube das Video haben wir schon mal geguckt von 2017. Und das ist ja ein ewig langes Video.
Ach das ist, das sind irgendwelche indischen Scammer die hier gebadet werden.
So, Heizung wieder aus. Dennoch, Leute, die Seite mit dem Flaschen habe ich gesehen, dass das auch ohne CPU funktioniert.
So, dann lassen wir uns mal von Levelcap, den habe ich schon ewig nicht geguckt von, erklären warum Battlefield 3 so nice war.
Gibt es viele Punkte warum Battlefield 3 so nice war. Mal gucken was Levelcap dazu sagt.
Ist Levelcap eigentlich noch angesagt? Was macht der aktuell für Games?
Battlefield 5? Rainbow Six? Wen gab es denn sonst noch? Es gab Levelcap und wie hieß der andere Dude Jack? Jack Frax. Gab es da noch früher wo die so Battlefield mäßig voll am Start waren. Der Mesh ist gefeatured.
Gibt es den anderen noch? Was macht der so? Warface? Fuck.
Der ist anscheinend noch deutlich angesagter als der andere. Der hat ein bisschen mehr Variation drin. Der macht Modern Warfare, Battlefield, Star Wars, PUBG, CSGO, Rainbow Six. Der hat ein bisschen mehr Variation drin.
Ich habe schon ganz vergessen, wie das sich anhört.
Über die Improvements kann man sich jetzt streiten.
Schon gelesen, dass 2020 zwei neue Fachrichtungen zum Fachinformatiker dazukommen. Nee. Nee. Hab ich nicht gelesen.
Oh Leute, wir müssen übrigens später noch einen Test machen. Und zwar es gibt jetzt von der Telekom, der Telekom Karriere-Matcher oder sowas gibt es von denen.
Karriere-Matcher, da kann man nämlich im Vorfeld der Karriere-Matcher, das müssen wir gleich mal machen, da muss man nämlich ein paar Fragen beantworten und kriegt dann raus, ob man zur Telekom passt.
Den machen wir gleich, den machen wir gleich nach dem Battlefield-Video. Ob wir die Magenta-DNA haben, genau. Was war das andere? Die Magenta-DNA und was war das andere?
We love Magenta, we are Magenta. Wie hieß der andere Hashtag? Wir hatten so zwei richtig Fremdschemen Hashtags am Start.
Magenta-DNA und was war das andere? Ich weiß es nicht mehr. Keine Ahnung. Ok, was? 2020 gibt es neue Fachinformatiker-Richtungen. Fachrichtungen oder wie soll man das nennen?
Neuordnung IT-Berufe, ok, zeig mal her. Ok, es gibt tatsächlich neue Fachinformatiker-Richtungen, gibt es das ab, gibt es das heute?
Hier, neue IT-Berufe. Zum 1. August 2020... Ok, also was gibt es denn? IT-System kauft man, IT-System-Elektronik... Gut, das werden immer weniger, ja, das macht auch keiner gerne.
Nach 23 Jahren, stimmt, das ist schon uralt. Also ich hab mal das hier gelernt vor 13 Jahren, schon ein bisschen her.
Ok, und wo steht jetzt, was es gibt? Bin ich jetzt blöd? Wo steht es denn? Was ist, was ist? Ah, hier. Hier.
Man hätte einfach mal so eine Tabelle machen können, heise alter. Das kann auch kein Mensch erkennen auf den ersten Blick. Ok, ähm...
Gut job, IHK. Man hat anhand des Namens schon mal keine Ahnung, was es sein soll. Das habt ihr gut gemacht.
Anstelle der bisherigen Zwischen- und Abschlussprüfung werden auswähle künftig eine sogenannte gestreckte Abschlusspro... What?
Oh, das wird für einige ziemlich sacken, alter. Das heißt, dass auch die Leistungen der Zwischenprüfung zur Abschlussnote beitragen.
Aber Leute, seid beruhigt, das ist nur für Leute, die neu anfangen anscheinend. Das ist nur für Leute, die neu anfangen.
Ich glaube, für Leute, die dieses Jahr noch anfangen, oder letztes Jahr angefangen haben, ist das egal.
Das ist für manche schlecht. Aktuell ist die Zwischenprüfung absolut irrelevant. Du kannst in der Zwischenprüfung nur 6 haben und das ist vollkommen wurscht.
Aktuell ist die Zwischenprüfung nur dafür da, dass man sehen kann, wie gut man mit IHK-Prüfungen durchkommt.
Matt, es ist alles an der Ausbildung easy. Es ist nichts Schwieriges. Trotzdem fallen Leute durch.
Berufsschule ist wirklich easy. Und auch die Ausbildung an sich, rein was die IHK will, ist easy as fuck.
Das, was kompliziert macht, ist je nachdem, was die Firma, wo du bist oder der Betrieb von dir will.
Also was schreiben die hier? 3 Jahre ist normal. Teil 1 der Prüfung mit 20% Gewichtung.
Prüfungsbereich ein Einrichten eines Artikels. Ist das euer Ernst?
Sind die bei der IHK, haben die jeglichen Realitätsbezug verloren?
Einrichten eines IT-gestützten Arbeitsplatzes. Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Das hat doch mit dem Inhalt, was Fachinformatiker heute machen, absolut nichts mehr zu tun.
Klar, du hast natürlich immer noch die ein oder anderen IT-Supportleute. Aber 98% der Leute haben damit überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Einrichten, oh meine Fresse.
Deine Parallelklasse ist fast voller First-Level-Supporter.
Betriebliche Projektarbeit. Berufsspezifische Aufgabe.
Ich brauche den Kotze-Emoji.
Hier kommt die Beschreibung, was die alles machen. Anwendungsentwicklung und Systemedikation, die gab es ja schon.
Was machen die Neuen? Digitale Vernetzung. Arbeit mit der Netzwerkinfrastruktur und den Schnittstellen zwischen Netzwerkkomponenten und Cyber.
Was ein Satz.
Cyber, physisch, was ist mit der IHK eigentlich los?
Ich meine, es ist ja nicht so, als gibt es in der IT-Welt nicht schon zu viele Buzzwords und Bullshit-Sätze.
Aber das da ist noch nicht mal ein Buzzword, das ist irgendwas, was sich die IHK ausgedacht hat.
Diese Bezeichnung habe ich noch nie gehört. Noch nie im Leben habe ich diese Bezeichnung gehört.
Und ich mache das schon seit über 13 Jahren. Ich habe es noch wirklich noch nie gehört. Cyber, physischen Systemen.
Was soll das überhaupt sein?
Ich kann mir da nichts darunter vorstellen.
Niklas2. Der Benutzer hat bereits für 5 Monate abonnet. Huge Play, danke schön.
Cyber, physischen Systemen, was auch immer.
Sie vernetzen und optimieren Systeme und Anwendungen auf IT-Ebene. Sie sichern Daten gegen unerlaubten Zugriffe und vermeiden behehmene Systemausfälle.
Das ist eigentlich genau das, was du hier unter anderem als Systemintegrator auch lernen solltest.
Vernetzte IT-Systeme. Was auch immer.
Was auch immer sich die IHK da überlegt hat.
Oh, es gibt einen Wikipedia-Eintrag fürs Cyber, phys, ernsthaft?
Es gibt ernsthaft einen Wikipedia-Eintrag dafür, krasser Scheiße.
So, was haben wir dort noch? Fachrichtung, Daten- und Prozessanalyse.
Das klingt mir so nach, was ich auf keinen Fall machen will.
Entwickelt auf Basis der Verfügbarkeit sowie Qualität und Quantität von... was?
IT-technische Lösung für zunehmend von Daten angetriebenen digitalen Produktionen.
Was?
Okay, nochmal.
Fachinformatikerinnen der Fachrichtung Daten- und Prozessanalyse.
Entwickelt auf Basis der Verfügbarkeit sowie Qualität und Quantität von Daten.
IT-technische Lösungen für zunehmend von Daten angetriebenen digitalen Produktions- und Geschäftsprozessen.
Ah, yes. Exzellent. Alles klar.
Alles klar, da weißt du sofort.
Also das ist, Leute, wenn ihr sowas lernen wollt, es fragt euch in Zukunft einer.
Und was stellen Sie sich von Ihrem Ausbildungsberuf, was stellen Sie sich in Ihrer Ausbildung so vor?
Da sagst du, ja, also ich stelle mir vor, als Fachinformatiker der Fachrichtung Daten- und Prozessanalyse
entwickle ich auf Basis der Verfügbarkeit sowie Qualität und Quantität von Daten in Zukunft
IT-technische Lösungen für zunehmend von Daten angetriebenen digitalen Produktions- und Geschäftsprozessen.
Da sag ich, bam, Sie haben den Job. Ganz klar.
Das ist ein Geschwätze, ey.
Das ganze IRK-Zeug ist so unglaublich unsinniger Crap, ey.
Berufsschule ist komplett sinnlos, lernste nix.
Und der ganze IRK-Apparat ist voll für'n Arsch.
Ich hab schon oft genug erzählt, wie sie mich durch die Abschlussprüfung haben durchfallen lassen,
weil ich angeblich meine Dokumentation nicht abgegeben habe.
Und, ähm, obwohl ich sie eingereicht hab, ich hab schon öfters erzählt, den ganzen Scheiß, ja.
Den ganzen Kackladen, da.
So, wir gucken uns jetzt das Battlefield-Video fertig, ey.
Wir ignorieren die IRK jetzt einfach.
BWL-Geblubber, ja, genauso liest sich das.
Ich hab dazu übrigens auch mal ein Video gemacht, wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Mal gucken, ob der ähnliche Sachen sagt wie ich.
Ich hab dazu auch ein Video gemacht, fällt mir gerade ein.
Wann war das?
Februar 2018.
Wie viel Aufrufe hat Mainz?
81.000 und wie viel hat...
Okay.
Levelcap hat das Zehnfache.
Ah, gut.
Best of.
Da hat er dazu auch ein Video gemacht.
Gucken wir uns das nächste Mal an.
Gucken wir mal, ich mach's schon mal auf, gucken wir uns das nächste Mal an.
Du meinst das hier, ne?
Ja, tja, da hat er Recht.
Mittlerweile ist Rush... ist Rush überhaupt im Game?
Es gab ja mal diese...
Es gab ja mal Rush, kurzzeitig, ich weiß nicht ob das immer noch so drin ist.
Suneh fragt, ich nutze derzeit oder sagt, ich nutze derzeit PhoneGap, um eine App zu basteln.
Stehe nun vor der Frage, wie und welche Datenbank ich nutzen möchte.
Bin mit nur HTML und...
Ja, was gibt...
Ich hab PhoneGap noch nie verwendet.
Local Storage?
Wenn das reines JavaScript ist?
Ich hab's noch nie verwendet, kein Schimmer.
Ich verwende immer gerne SQLite, wenn das so ne simple Geschichte ist.
SQLite ist für simple Sachen eigentlich so das Beste.
Ich weiß aber nicht, wie es mit SQLite für Apps aussieht.
Keine Ahnung.
Ehrlich, legit kein Schimmer.
Wenn es aber HTML JavaScript ist, dass es fast wahrscheinlich nur ein Browser in der eigenen...
Als Browser als App ist, kann sich einfach Local Storage irgendwas speichern.
Ich meine das Video, das dir bei YouTube oben rechts...
Hype and Masterpiece.
Hype and Master...
I want you to think, das ist das, was ich mehr oder weniger auch über das Game gesagt hab in meinem Video, wo es um das Thema ging.
Einfach, dass das Game genau zur richtigen Zeit rauskam und die Erwartungen erfüllt hat.
Und die...
Es hat...
Es hat kaum ein Battlefield-Game so lange so nen Hype gehabt wie Battlefield 3 am Stück.
Und so viele interessierte Spieler.
Die Spieler waren in Battlefield 3 eingeloggt bis zum Tag, wo Battlefield 4 released wurde und danach ging es abwärts.
Ich würde auch Battlefield 3 sagen, wobei ich hin und her gerissen zwischen Bad Company 2 und Battlefield 3 bin.
Aber wahrscheinlich würde ich auch Battlefield 3 sagen.
Das stimmt, hat er recht.
Ja.
Doch, du bist so...
...gripp direkt weg.
Das stimmt wohl, ja.
Headshots waren so ein bisschen problematisch in Battlefield 3.
Vor allem hier, wenn die Leute über Sachen drüber gesprungen sind, weil halt die Gegner komplett hin und her gejumpt sind mit diesen...
...also mit den teilweise schlecht interpolierten Animationen.
Der ist hier drüber gesprungen und hat dann gemacht...
...und da konntest du nicht wirklich gescheit aimen.
Deswegen im besten Battlefield 3 war einfach irgendwo...
...irgendwo draufsprayen auf den Körper und...
...gut war.
Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Ja, das stimmt.
Das stimmt.
Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Ja, ja, ja.
Das stimmt.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ja, ja, ja.
Ja, ja.
My.
auf jeden fall auch an den maps aber auch das handling von den panzern muss ich sagen im battlefield 4 auch aber ich fand's auch cool so sachen mit
canister shell und
canister shell
und main gun switchen und sowas
man konnte ja noch switchen auf den gunner seat und solche geschichten am besten war natürlich wenn du noch einen dabei hast der dich repariert hat oder
also die leute die ja die aktiv panzer gespielt haben im team die haben ja dann auch teilweise zwei leute gehabt die repariert haben
das war schon cool das war schon cool und du konntest ja auch wenn du richtig nice warst
konntest du ja auch mit deinem tank javelines ausweichen
konnte ich nie gibt da videos zu also man konnte man konnte javelines ausweichen mit seinem panzer wenn man das richtig getimt hat
und das war wirklich schwer
und das was ich an dem time von battlefield 3 nicht wirklich
an dem time von battlefield 3 nicht richtig getimiert hat war das Lack des Gadgets Spanns es sah so aus als ob die designer des Spiels es fühlte sich mehr an wie wenn man eigentlich in einem Militär war wo jeder eine bestimmte Rolle hatte und nicht jeder Spieler in dem Spiel irgendeinen verrückten Gadget hatte, der die Explosionen auf dem Bild hinzugefügt hat sie wollten es mehr um den Gunplay zu sein und es ist mehr um den Gunplay zu sein es ist meistens um den Gunplay zu sein du wirst sterben um Assault Rifles und Sniper Rifles und Maschinengrenzen und DMRs mehr so als
ich finde auch das ist die Zerstörung die Zerstörung hat sich in Battlefield 3 auch richtig angefühlt ja die war nicht so übertrieben dass man gesagt hat wir brauchen jetzt feste Punkte auf der Map die Revolution machen sondern die war halt einfach da aber halt nicht nicht so übertrieben in your face um geil zu sein sondern sie war einfach da und hat gut funktioniert man konnte auch nicht alles killen was auch sehr sinnvoll war weil die Struktur der Map musste vorhanden bleiben
also das war ja im Prinzip die Zerstörung von Bad Company 2 zu Battlefield 3 war ja insofern an manchen Stellen ein Rückschritt dass man keine Häuser mehr einstürzen lassen konnte
bis auf manche Häuser wobei ich glaube manche Häuser gingen in Battlefield 3 kaputt zu machen oder ich glaube manche Sachen gingen noch kaputt aber die Häuser mit einer Treppe gingen definitiv nicht kaputt alle Häuser mit einer Treppe wusstest du diesen Safe Form einstürzen du konntest nur die Mauern kaputt schießen und das fand ich eigentlich ganz cool
Bad Company 2 war halt nice dass du die Häuser einschürzen lassen konntest aber du hattest in Bad Company 2 oftmals das Problem Bad Company 2 hatte halt viele relativ große naturbezogene Maps also hier Waldparaiso oder Pornwall das halt sehr sehr environment basiert und wenn da halt alle Häuser weg waren da war halt flach da ging nix mehr und das war hier eigentlich ganz gut
es dauerte ein bisschen um sie zu schießen es dauerte ein bisschen um sie zu zerstören und ein guter Spieler konnte die Grenade meistens ausbreiten also du konntest es meistens nur zu benutzen um jemanden aus dem Hinterkopf auszulösen
es war eine tolle Balance zwischen Geräten und eigentlichen Waffen mit der Emphasis auf der Waffe
ich fand auch den Medic Spam in Battlefield 3 gut
ich mein es war so es war es hatte Nachteile muss man auch klar sagen dieses dieses dieses Dauer Red Strain Geschichte war nicht jedermanns Fall in Battlefield 3 was ich allerdings gut fand und was so noch kein anderes Battlefield Spiel gepackt hat dadurch dass das Medic eigentlich so pauschal erstmal wenn man nicht wusste was man picken sollte oder nicht situationsbedingt gepickt hat hat man Medic gepickt oder Assault gepickt immer das war so erstmal die beste Allround Klasse in dem Ganzen wenn nicht die beste Klasse im Ganzen
Spiel und dementsprechend war halt auch an jeder Ecke irgendeinen Medic am Start und ich wurde in keinem Battlefield Spiel davor und in keinem Battlefield Spiel danach so oft wiederbelebt wie in Battlefield 3 und das hat dem Teamplay und dem Fluss und der Geschwindigkeit alles echt gut genommen
das stimmt das stimmt Suppression war auch immer einer der Faktoren wo ich gesagt habe die könnten wir ein bisschen zurückschrauben die waren die fand ich auch zu übertrieben
erinnert ihr euch noch an die Taschenlampen am Anfang die so als sie ins Gesicht geleuchtet haben als wäre vor die gerade die Sonne aufgegangen
Battlefield 3 machte es das Beste oder das Schlimmste anhand deiner Perspektiven und sie hatten auch sehr briefe Sonnenblasen die auf deinem Fernseher riefen
die Devs oder eher die Künstler wollten dieses Spiel wirklich aussehen wie ein Film und das kann zu einer gewissen extent cool sein, außer wenn du ein Spiel spielst das sehr taktisch und skillorientiert ist und die visualen Effekte einfach in die Weise deiner Skill und Strategie kommen und sie haben viel gemacht in Battlefield 3
eine der größten Anmerkungen dieses Spiels war das Blutent und das Sonnenblasen
naja Unity Media wieder
um die Frage zu beantworten hier von Michael im Chat er hat gefragt Max würdest du es einem empfehlen den PC ab und zu neu aufzusetzen also komplett platt machen halt? Nö warum? Wenn alles funktioniert gibt es überhaupt keinen Grund
ja das war das beste was ich gerade gesagt habe Assault war die beste Allround Klasse und dadurch wurde man einfach wiederbelebt das fand ich gut
ich fand es ist doch viel frustrierender als du legst ewig rum und wirst nie wiederbelebt das ist das beste gewesen an Battlefield 3
und dann hat man wieder ein halbes Team steht wieder